vous m'avez placé en tête du premier
tour des élections régionales
et je veux vous en remercier sincèrement
j'ai mis toute mon énergie tout mon
coeur dans cette campagne et ce résultat
renforce ma détermination mon envie me
battre pour vous dans cette campagne
j'ai porté vos priorités l'emploi qui
est mon combat
la sécurité pour mieux vous protéger et
l'écologie une écologie qui rassemble
une écologie des résultats j'ai porté la
défense de notre modèle celui d'une
région où il fait bon vivre étudier
travailler élever ses enfants et
vieillir paisiblement une région qui a
surmonté la crise qui va de l'avant une
région forte dynamique et solidaire je
suis candidate pour défendre cette
région que nous aimons tant face à nous
la gauche est prête à tout à toutes les
compromissions à toutes les alliances
cette gauche dure cette gauche alliée à
jean luc mélenchon veut casser notre
économie casser notre industrie casser
nos forces et notre équilibre
pas une voix pas une voix ne doit
manquer pour faire barrage à cette
gauche extrême je suis une femme ouverte
une femme de dialogue
je sais que l'on peut réussir
qu'ensemble quand nous unissant je tends
la main à tous ceux qui n'ont pas voté
pour moi et qui partagent nos valeurs de
la liberté du travail de la
responsabilité
ensemble nous pouvons faire le choix
d'une région qui rassemble et qui va de
l'avant
j'ai besoin de vous et je compte sur
vous
[Musique]